iphone 14
iphone 14 plus iphone 14 pro and iphone
14 pro max yes there are four new iphone
14s but only two of them have this cool
new always on display and then two have
6.7 inch displays but there's a 200
price difference between them
oh and the apple watch ultra yeah
there's a lot but that's why i came here
to sweltering cupertino oh i will take a
cooling towel the most refreshing thing
apple did and announced today i have
braved the heat and a lot of people to
help you understand these new iphone 14
models let's break it down going from
the most affordable to the most
expensive
ever let's start with the 800 sorry 799
iphone 14. it looks a lot like the
iphone 13 and 12 for that matter with
the same 6.1 inch oled screen
what's better well the cameras at least
according to apple the 12 megapixel wide
camera has a new sensor that apple says
delivers major improvements in low light
video should also be more stable with a
new action mode that will stabilize your
footage one of the cooler things that i
can't demo here is a new emergency sos
via satellite feature all of the iphone
14 models can make calls using satellite
technology that is when there isn't
cellular connectivity it won't be out
until november though
speaking of the iphone and emergencies
the iphone 14 models also have a car
crash detection mode that will sense if
you've been in a crash and alert
emergency services yeah there's a lot of
new buy this or die kind of features
also completely gone the sim card slot
next up the chain the iphone 14 plus
starting at 899
see apple killed the iphone mini in the
lineup and added this big 6.7 inch
iphone 14 plus not to be confused with
the iphone 14 pro max it's identical to
the iphone 14 with the same cameras and
processor but it has a bigger screen and
longer battery life in fact apple says
the best battery life ever in an iphone
but for the best new features you've got
to go up to the iphone 14 pro which
starts at 999 dollars
you're not going to believe this
but the notch is gone
kind of
apple has shrunk down that area where
the selfie camera and the face id tech
live into this new area which has
allowed them to pave the way for a
secret place called the dynamic island
the dynamic island the dynamic island
the dynamic island uh yeah i don't know
who in the marketing team approved that
name but the feature is kind of cool i'm
playing this great song by the imagine
dragons
i swipe up
and it goes right up in here into the
dynamic island then i can set a timer i
swipe up again
and it goes into
the dynamic eyelet there's also an
always-on display which i'm pretty
excited about it means that the
background dims to just show you vital
information so you no longer need to
keep tapping to see the time or the date
and you can always turn off the always
on display in settings the big deal the
three cameras on the back the main wide
camera specifically is 48 megapixels
compared to 12 megapixels on last year's
iphone 13 pro the pros also have new a16
bionic processors
and finally the iphone 14 pro max which
starts at 10.99 it's really the same
phone as that 14 pro but with a bigger
6.7 inch screen and better battery life
the event today wasn't only about
iphones apple also announced the apple
watch series 8 which has a new
temperature sensor meant to aid with
fertility tracking
but the big deal was the apple watch
ultra which is aimed at extreme sports
athletes time for a bigger wrist it has
a larger 49-millimeter titanium case new
action buttons on the side a built-in
scuba diving computer and 36 hours of
battery life so now you know which
iphone is which i think but which one do
you get well you'll have to stay tuned
for our full reviews to find that out
the eye towel no battery needed